every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed you know I bet you'd be fine
without me hello everybody welcome to a
special episode of the minimalists
podcast my name is Joshua fields
Millburn and what you're about to hear
is a live version of our podcast which
Ryan and I recorded a few months ago
while we are on tour with our
documentary which is called minimalism a
documentary about the important things
we went to about 15 different cities and
this live recording happened at a
double-header event in Chicago Illinois
and we had some friends with us as well
the executive producers of our
documentary Jeff and Marla and Dave who
run a company called aspire they're
amazing part of our team at the
minimalists they handle a lot of our
design and development work on our
website but they also helped immensely
with this film and getting it out into
the world and so we brought them up on
the stage and answered some questions
some audience questions about the film
and about minimalism decluttering and
and just a bunch of different things in
front of this Chicago crowd speaking of
our film it's finally available online
if you haven't checked it out yet you
can do so over at minimalism film calm
thank you so much to everyone who has
supported this thanks to you it's right
now the number one in the documentary of
2016 and people in over a hundred
countries have seen this film now which
just blows my mind so we I was looking
at these numbers the other day and
seeing people not just in the United
States and Australia and Canada and the
UK which are some of the most popular
countries for minimalism but people in
Saudi Arabia and Ethiopia and Latvia and
Brazil and Argentina and Mexico all of
these different places across the world
more than a hundred countries this
message is spreading so thank you for
sharing this message with your friends
your family your love
ones in an effort to add value to their
lives I really hope you enjoy this live
version of our podcast and stay tuned
after this episode Sean is going to
insert some listener comments from past
episodes also our next podcast episode
which Ryan and I recorded a while ago
we're gonna put it in the feed and a
couple weeks here make sure you're
subscribed to to the podcast if you want
to check out our next episode about
criticism but if you have a comment on
criticism how do you handle criticism
we'd love to hear from you and we love
to air it on our next episode just give
us a call at four oh six two one nine
seven eight three nine now without
further ado here is a live version of
our ask the minimalists podcast in front
of a live audience in chicago illinois
with jeff marla and dave and of course
Ryan and me answering your questions
well hello Chicago welcome to a live
version of the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and today we have some
special guests with us the folks from
spire we have Dave we have Jeff and we
have Marla they're executive producers
of the film but they're also just an
amazing part of the minimalist team give
them a round of applause please so you
can ask whatever you want I promise you
will get an answer we have 12 answers up
here tonight and and one of them will be
randomly chosen for your questions so
feel free to come on up and we'll will
answer your questions just give us your
name and whatever whatever question is
sure Ryan I'm curious about your
haircare products I'm thinking about and
integrating with my own now I think that
my wife and I Tiffany we've heard the
gospel we are connected but not really
to the film necessarily but helping out
our parents and our relatives those in
our 60s and 70s we see their homes we
see their junk
and it makes us scoff and ethically I
don't know what to do I don't want to
press the issue too hard to make people
feel uncomfortable but yet and still I
feel that I need to do something and I'm
struggling at how to you know reach our
family and to do those things and if you
guys have any recommendations on how to
connect with the older populations of 67
to 70 subs that'd be awesome thank you
certainly you know it's a very nice way
to say how do I force my parents become
minimalist right no I don't think that's
this question but but quite often we do
get similar questions to that it usually
has to do with with people living
together where it's like how do I force
my significant other who's a maximalist
to become a minimalist and I'm like well
you don't that's that's really not what
you do in fact when I first introduced
Ryan to minimalism it wasn't through the
actions
it wasn't the Hal - it wasn't hey Ryan
come over to my house I can show you how
I declutter in my closet I never jumped
up and said look at me you're become B
I'm becoming a minimalist I'm getting
all this stuff and Ryan you want to be
my friend you better become a minimalist
too because you have a lot of junk no
the truth is that that when he came to
me he said why the hell are you so happy
it was because he saw the benefits of
minimalism and people at work notice -
you know I was working in 80 hours a
week 362 days a year I was director of
operations for 150 retail stores which I
know is really ironic with the whole
minimalism thing and um people at work
started saying you know what's going on
with you you seem calmer you seem less
stressed what the hell's going on you
seem so much happier tell me about
what's going on and when Ryan came to me
and said you know why the hell are you
so happy I that opened the door for
minimalism for me and and I didn't even
put that label on it because for some
people a label like that is really scary
right for some people it's like oh now I
can finally identify this thing that
I've been trying to use to simplify my
life for other people it's like it's a
big turn-off and and and so the the idea
with the film was okay minimalism we
know is a scary title
how can we make it less scary make it
more approachable and really showing
people what the benefits are I find is
is the best way to do that and so I
would say start with the benefits and
and really starting with a question how
might your life be better with less if
you ask that question it helps you
understand what the benefits of
minimalism are which is far more
important than the how-to it's the why
to portion it gives you the leverage you
need to actually do the Halla two-part
we all know instinctually how to
declutter our closet right I mean it's a
relatively easy thing to do how to
declutter our homes how to organize but
we don't always know why we're doing
that what's the purpose behind it so for
me it started with finances I made
really good money in the corporate world
but I spent even better money and that
equation just does not work and so I had
racked up throughout my 20s massive
amounts of debt six figures worth of
debt and so I realized that by regaining
control of the way I consume I would
spend less money and start to regain
control of my finances which means I
could start paying off debt but then all
of these other benefits started peeking
their head around the corner regaining
control of my health I used to weigh 80
pounds more than I weigh now regaining
control of my relationships I forsook
the people closest to me because I was
spending so much time with networking
buddies and co-workers and and
relationships birthed out of convenience
and proximity but not the people who
were really closest to me so I was
making more time for the people in my
life I just had more time in general for
creativity or passion I had time to
contribute to the the community in a
different way than I ever had before and
so identifying what those benefits are
and they're different for everyone
you know I've two and a half year old
now and the benefits for her gonna be
appreciably different from me a 34 year
old guy and even though the benefits
from my 34 year old self are different
from my 29 year old self or from my 45
year old self a decade from now and so I
didn't find those benefits help it
really helps people get the leverage
they need to really get started and then
once you get started it's about figuring
out what actually adds value to your
life it's not about deprivation it's
about moving forward and direct
of of consuming responsibly consuming
the things that do add value getting rid
of that which is superfluous I want to
preface this with the fact that my
parents are in the audience and and they
are not minimalists which is okay and I
think that it's important not to force
your values on other people to lead by
example is I think the best well I found
to be a middle most easiest thing to do
is just give your stuff to other people
that are in your life it's it's so much
easier just pop I did that to Ryan at
first when I was first simplifying he
was had 70 ties of mine that I was just
handing off to him PhD people like all
the all the people that were in the
documentary how did you find them so
some we went out what's your name by the
way
Hana Lee it's great to meet you thanks
thanks for asking that question I
appreciate it how did we find them Ryan
Twitter
no we there were a lot of people who we
looked up to and who we had
relationships with like Leo like Joshua
Becker and you know - Josh's point kind
of what he was saying in his answer to
the previous question we really wanted
to choose people who we looked up to who
did have this different flavor of
minimalism and incorporated into the
documentary so right away you know I'm
thinking like alright what minimalist
families are out there that that we can
incorporate into this because that's one
question we would get all the time and
we still do and we have a you know our
answer used to be well you know you
really don't want you know a single 35
year old single guy telling you what to
do with your kids and then we would like
kind of recommend other things and
recommend Leo recommend Joshua Becker so
it was it was kind of a no-brainer to
like get these guys in there and then
there were other people like Sam Harris
who was a neuroscientist who we really
looked up to and we did I think we you
started the conversation on Twitter with
them yeah seriously yeah I was just a
fan of his work and and didn't
necessarily agree with all of his
viewpoints and that's what I liked about
about this is we wanted to even put in
some contrasting viewpoints I don't
agree with every viewpoint that's
necessarily in the film Rick Hanson when
he talks about you know money can buy
happiness up to a certain point I I
don't completely agree with that I think
it's more nuanced than that I think true
money doesn't buy happiness but but
neither does poverty and and and so
striking a balance and I think an
arbitrary number like $70,000 is not
necessarily accurate for for most of us
because I could say I walked away from
the corporate world I made about 10
percent of what I was making in the
corporate world when I first walked away
and I had was measurably happier almost
immediately but it was sustainable
happiness as well and it's because I
stopped chasing happiness right and I
think that's a distinction to make is if
you're chasing if you're trying to chase
happiness you should probably stop
because because the more we chase
happiness the farther away
yet so when there was someone like Sam
Harris and I said well well well what's
the science behind that because it's
great that we have some some anecdotal
evidence here but let's talk to some
people who really know are the cognitive
function how our brain functions and and
try to apply that so we found all these
different people quite often from other
people we interviewed so you call you
saw Colin Beavan in here and he
mentioned the economist Julia Shore
well we've went out and found her and we
interviewed her and you know read a
bunch of books from from these different
people and realized these different
perspectives were necessary to really
flush out the story
yeah Frank the architect he was hosting
the event that we had in Tucson where
you saw Josh and I up on the stage when
we were sitting behind the table he was
the guy hosting it for us and afterwards
he was like man you guys are like right
up my alley and started telling us how
he was a minimalist architect and Matt
Tavella our director was with us and he
was like we go to your house and like
interview you and in film your house and
it just kind of worked out that way so
we use a few different avenues but uh
really happy with with the different
perspectives and diversity we we got in
the film okay person by name's Tiffany
I'm married to Larry question personally
about I I've watched a lot of the
YouTube and follow things and Instagram
and all of that but I never found an
answer to this question of why them
moved to Montana and how that relates to
the minimalism journey and just we lived
in California for 10 years we've been
here for two years and I really do think
place and location you know really can
impact lifestyle so wondering how that
decision happened did you decide
together did one of you go on the other
move and just personal question about
that decision especially because I saw
that Dayton is your favorite City so I'm
wondering kind of what's that connection
between the favorite city but not living
in the favorite so yeah so we're from
Dayton Ohio yeah
the gym city so yeah I spent the first
31 years of my life there and absolutely
loved the city but but also I also I
also understand the need for for variety
in life so Ryan and I were on our first
book tour where occasion it was more of
like a one-on-one meetup group because
we show up and two people would be there
and we just have a conversation we never
got shut out though that's true we
didn't and and you know eventually the
crowds really swelled to upwards of six
to eight people and and so now this has
been a really beautiful accident so
selling out a theater like this twice in
one night was never something that we
ever anticipated in fact this the first
time we've ever charged for events and
in our life
we've always our business model has
always been to spend as much money as we
have to go out and give out free hugs
we're still figuring out the the the way
to make profit off of that no we were
out we had left Vancouver BC and we had
we were fine it was a 33rd city on this
tour when we were finally going back
home to Dayton Ohio and we knew we had
to drive through this big state called
Montana and I'd never even thought about
Montana and so we're like we have to
drive that through there okay let's just
get through today and we woke up in
Coeur d'Alene Idaho and we just started
driving through Montana and it was
cliche gorgeous it was like you have to
use stock phrases from from like Keats
poems or something to describe this
place and and so we were driving through
there and it continued to get more
gorgeous into the point where it looked
like an Abercrombie & Fitch ad like like
there are major brands who you use
demographers and in designers to curate
the way that Montana just looks by
itself and we were driving by we were
driving on i-90 and it's the first time
in my life I've ever done a triple take
we're driving and there's this waterfall
like a small waterfall on the side of
the road and there are
college kids who were skinny-dipping
jumping from the this rock platform into
the waterfall and in right as I did this
triple take I [ __ ] you not a bald eagle
flew right overhead I'm from Dayton Ohio
I've never seen a bald eagle in my life
I mean the only thing more cliche if it
was would have had like a American flag
in its talons or something but and I
just looked at Ryan I'm like man we
we've got to come back out here at least
some point so we moved and that was
summer which is the time to go to
Montana we moved back out there that
fall in winter to write a book called
everything that remains and we moved to
this cabin in the middle of nowhere on
the side of a mountain and let me tell
you chopping firewood like Thoreau and
Montana winter when it's negative 28
degrees is fun for 4 minutes but we
stayed out there for four months wrote
the first draft of this book and we
found ourselves once a week once every
other week gravitating toward this
booming metropolis called Missoula
Montana there's 70,000 people there
second-largest city in the state but a
lot of culture per capita and and we
knew that that was the next place we
wanted to go to on our journey and I
can't tell you that I will definitely
stay there forever but it's it's the
most gorgeous place I've ever been
hi Katie I actually have a two-part
question a three-part answer okay great
ready for it um so the first question is
you did a really good job showing how
you really have cleared so much out of
your physical spaces at home I'm curious
is there like one or two things that you
gave away and you're like oh [ __ ] like I
really need that and you asked for it
back like was it the one pair of
underwear you need eight instead of
seven curious just you know from your
standpoint if and what that happened to
what it was my second question is I am
myself creating a documentary this year
for the first time and yeah I applaud
you it's fantastic though and what's
your advice for documentary filmmakers
I never even like consider myself a
filmmaker - I'll answer the first part
you tell her how to be a good filmmaker
you know I I haven't really like
regretted anything I've given away I had
a twinge the beginning of this year my
my mother my grandmother my two brothers
and my sister came out to visit us in
Missoula Montana I've got a two-bedroom
apartment it was like packed to the
gills it was it was crazy and I often
like how people come through and visit
so it wasn't that big of a deal but I I
didn't have like I realized like oh man
I don't have like the the sheets and all
the blankets and stuff like man and I
got rid of some of those things and like
I went to Josh and I went to his
girlfriend Becks and I was like you guys
like I said sheets some blankets I can
use in there like yeah we sure do so
like they totally hooked me up so it was
like a little bit of a twinge but then
realized very quickly that that I could
certainly find someone to like lend that
stuff to me um had another twinge they
were coming out I was like really
excited to take my brothers snowboarding
and I'm like talking to my mom I'm like
you guys have snow gear and she's like
no we don't have any of that stuff
and my girlfriend I had just got new
pairs of snow pants and had donated our
old pairs and I was like crap like I
just got rid of two pair of snow pants
like that would have been perfect for my
you know my sister and one of my
brothers and and I'm like man might we
need to go to like you know the sporting
goods store and buy a really cheap pair
of snow pants and then hold on to them
if a case I need them and and I'm
talking to Mariah about it and she's
like you know I think I think my mom's
got some extra stuff like she from when
we were kids like she's got some stuff
there and when when we go down there and
when family visits they always need
stuff and I think you might be able to
borrow some stuff for them so like sure
enough called them up we got one pair of
snow pants cause some other friends up
my mom was able to find one in Ohio so I
have had these twinges where I was like
[ __ ] I wish I didn't get rid of that but
very quickly found a substitute found
another way to kind of get past it how
to be a documentary filmmaker
this is a good question
none of us have done anything like this
before so this is all completely new we
really diving in it is so important to
have a team a team of people can take
different perspectives on things these
guys have had all the connections and
set everything up his producers setting
up all the interviews and whatnot
Matt the director he did he was the
editor he shot he he's super scrappy
Whedon we did so much with six people
that it's really just it's always gonna
be bigger than you anticipate and it's
gonna take a lot more time but the
biggest thing that we learned was to
show it to people I mean obviously
you're seeing it now it's awesome we
love it and we hope you loved it too but
this is not the first version of the
film we've had so many revisions the
very first version went over exceedingly
well the more people that saw it the
more we really saw it we were missing
just some key audiences some key
demographics people who were just maybe
not connecting with the film and the way
that we hoped that they would so we
really went back we had all this footage
it's amazing stuff and we just went back
and rethought you know how can we
address these issues that that we may
have missed and the first go around so
really I mean the two things would be
surround yourself with some people who
you can really just truly rely on and
Trust to do a great job and also really
show this show your work show your work
and you're gonna get some great feedback
I just got the the wrap-up signal from
Sean we're gonna do one more question
but dave has you good yeah original
question about things of getting rid of
stuff a couple years ago I decided I was
getting rid of all of my art work that
I'd done for the previous decade it was
on about 400 DVDs and the first DVD yes
there was like that a bit of pain but
then it was just so easy and I realized
the joy was in making it not holding on
to all this
stuff right like just digital files at
this point I had already enjoyed making
it and putting it into the world I
didn't need to hold on to it anymore and
I think it's just taking that first step
of just getting rid of some stuff and it
starts to become freeing except just
carrying these 400 DVDs around without a
DVD player for like literally 12 years
and is ridiculous so what we'll do one
last question Sean's told me to wrap up
here I'm so you've conveyed your message
through you know your blog your books
your now you've got a movie in the
podcast I was just wondering if you have
any new ideas of you know more content
you've been kicking around and you know
not just platforms to convey that
content but just content in general if
you just have any more ideas you've been
tossing around yes so minimalism and 3d
virtual reality minimalism no you know
it's interesting I think it's it's
interesting question because my answer
right now would be appreciably different
from what it was six years ago I wanted
I initially started out writing fiction
so this whole nonfiction thing was Ryan
said hey we should start a website we
didn't even know was what's called a
blog at the time and and we wanted to
share our story and so I found out that
nonfiction was appreciably different
from from fiction and but that's what I
had written for a long time and so I
wanted to be an author I won the right
books books with the things I wanted to
write I enjoyed reading them I wanted to
write them it was just books books books
and then Ryan's like what about a
website okay it's not that different
what yeah actually was but it was a
different vehicle but it still allowed
me to write and then we started using
other vehicles and I became over time
vehicle agnostic where social media was
one way to communicate the blog was one
way to communicate email was a way to
communicate the podcast is a way to
communicate and now a documentary is the
way to communicate in the future I'd
love to do some
videoworks um maybe some video essays
we're also talking to some folks about
doing like an online web series for a TV
show kind of thing maybe a network TV
show I really don't know but whatever it
is it needs to it needs to align with
our values and we tend to focus on only
one project a year so in 2014 we went on
the road with we donated a year of our
lives basically ten months
to going on that hundred City tour and
119 events eight countries and last year
was a year of contribution we opened up
a Elementary School and Laos we funded a
high school for a year we did a bunch of
just projects to to contribute to the
world and in a way and this year it's to
get this documentary round the world
share this different perspective and I
can tell you whatever we decide to do
next year whatever our focus is next
year is going to be deliberate or we're
gonna make sure whatever we do is is
intentional and the it's not going to be
perfect but we're gonna absolutely put
our best foot forward so Anna Shan has
given me the the staredown right now I
want to thank so first I want to thank a
few people before before we go I'll tell
you right now this is a lot of work and
all the behind the scenes stuff the man
behind the minimalism is a guy named
Sean Harding he's the producer of her
podcast he edits our books he he does
everything that we need him to do and so
much more and we couldn't do this
without him so let's give Shawn Hardin
round of applause
and how about the folks from spire let's
let's thank them for being a part of us
thank you so much and oh I know Ryan
when we Raul is Raul here tonight you
could raise your hand yeah so so back in
2014 we went on the road people always
ask us how do I connect with supportive
open-minded people and we always said I
don't know you're here for a day and
then we're gone yes but in into 2014 we
left behind a hundred free local meetup
groups we don't want anything from you
but if you're interested in connecting
with open-minded like-minded people
supportive people you could talk about
minimalism you could talk about
relationships you can you can also be
supportive to other people you can
contribute beyond yourself which is
really awesome it's about 400 people
here I think it's one of our largest
minimalist org meetup group so you just
go to minimalist org and click on on
Chicago and you can find your city here
or there's a hundred other cities as
well and you can connect with some
open-minded people they meet once or
twice a month gentle there's twice a
month here and what's that at least
twice a month here so overachiever MLS
and if you go on the guys from spire
they go every once in a while to the
meetups too so so yeah you could ask
them more about how to create an awesome
documentary and we're on the road this
this month we decided to twelve and a
half cities instead of a hundred this
time and it's really expensive to tour
like this and especially we filmed a
documentary with a zero dollar budget
and and so we're out here on the road
right now and when we started the blog
six years ago we didn't have any idea
what to do and there's a company called
Bluehost that has helped us with our
hosting for several years now and I we
had we reached out to them and said hey
will you help us pay for some of the
travel for the store and and they said
yes so I'd like to thank them and give
them a round of applause they're one of
the reasons we're here tonight
most important I want to thank you all
for being here you could be anywhere in
the world you decide to spend an evening
with us and we're so grateful if you
leave here with one message I hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works we'll be out
there with free hugs see you soon
hi my name is Brooke Ramsey I just
listened to your guys's podcast on stuff
and I found it really inspiring and I
had a little comment about one of the
people who called in who really loved
scrapbooking and had a hobby that
consisted of a lot of things and I kind
of related to that a little bit one of
my hobbies is crochet I really love to
crochet and as I was downsizing my
things
I was wondering like what to do with all
of the yarn that I had leftover and a
solution that I came to was it I first
decluttered all of the yarn that I
wasn't inspired by first like the
textures but I didn't like and own the
colors that I didn't like and then what
was left I used it to make like one
gigantic blanket and I had so much fun
doing it and it's a blanket that my
partner and I like use and treasure and
it's one of the best summer blankets
that you can have so if you have a hobby
that involves a lot of things that does
legitimately bring you joy maybe
downsize it as much as you can and then
actively use those things to do the
thing that makes you happy especially if
using it equals using it up and
downsizing it
hi guys this is Kylee I'm calling from
Los Angeles California so I'm calling
just with a comment I'm listening to an
episode and you touch on gift-giving as
a love language every so often and
particularly I think Ryan said or maybe
was Josh I'm sorry one of you said that
gift-giving as a love language is
ridiculous or something like that
personally I agree that's not a language
that I speak in my relationship but um
you know I I hesitate to say something
like that about the way that someone
else wants to show affection just a tip
for some people who maybe that is a love
language that they speak or that their
partner's speak one thing that I do with
my partner is um if I know maybe I know
he so currently he needs a new wallet or
if I just do something that I think he
would like or appreciate rather than buy
it for him I'll take a picture of it and
send it to him or send him a link to the
thing and say hey I saw this and I think
you'd really like it you know here's
access to it so so then he has the
option to think a little bit about it
you know maybe he spends 30 days and
decide if it's something that would
really add value to his life so my gift
to him is really the attention that I'm
paying and the fact that I'm thinking of
him throughout the day or maybe the
research and the time that I'm putting
in to find those things for him but I'm
not spending money on a physical object
that he may or may not want and he does
the same thing for me which is really
great and between the two of us we get a
lot of product research done we we
really spend a lot of time thinking
about the things we want to bring into
our lives but we're we're doing it
together as an activity and as a gift to
one another so hopefully that's helpful
to anyone that's struggling with that
honey my name is Elizabeth my city is
Oklahoma City hey Josh and Ryan I wanted
to respond to the caller in episode 14 -
the woman who
is frustrated with moving several times
cleaning out her apartment and then
accumulating things again every time I
wanted to say I have 100% experiences I
moved to Germany with nothing I
accumulated minimum I accumulated again
I moved to Oklahoma minimized
accumulated again and now I'm getting
ready to move to Chicago and I'm
minimizing me again but I think finally
this time I'm doing it in a measured and
lasting way I never found the advice of
does this add value to my life really
enough to stop my shopping habit there's
a constant carload of things coming into
the apartment and another carload of
things going to Goodwill a lot of money
and a lot of waste and I just couldn't
seem to really stop the spending habit I
could never really just be happy with
what I had I always said of course this
is going to add value to my life I'm
going to upgrade X and Y and I'm going
to replace it with Z and ay and
everything's going to be awesome what I
found that really stopped the shopping
habit in a really concrete way was
thanking my possessions for doing a good
job this is from the Kumari method book
the art of tidying and is probably the
most concrete piece of advice that I've
given to so many of my friends who are
frustrated with consumerism and
purchasing and overdoing their
credit-card bills is if you appreciate
what you have then you won't be funding
and the way that I appreciated what I
had was to say physically say thank you
to my purse for holding my objects and
say thank you to my coat for keeping me
warm and once I started physically
thanking my items I finally felt that
appreciation that everybody had been
talking about but that I just didn't
understand like I finally truly
appreciate my items I felt really doing
it at first but this practice has 100%
curbed my need to shop at the tomb I am
finally happy and satisfied with
everything that I have
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without every little
thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you got hey you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without you
so tell your team
you